foreign
[Music]
you always heard the stories about TB
throwing away Welker and moss in LA and
you know you have Gronk come out here so
you know after my first year I was like
yo Steve my agent you know I was like
give me a place in La and let Brady know
I'm gonna be out there yeah just in case
he wants to throw you know I wanna I
wanna throw with them I want to be
around them and you do that like
multiple you're just like trying to get
his attention trying to be like yo I
will be your your dude I just wanted to
be available that's right you know
because I mean I was still like a slap
dick at the time I had some run and some
burn my rookie year but you know there
was Wes Welker and he was a [ __ ] stud
yeah you know I was a transferring
positions from quarterback to receiver
and I was still learning my game I was
still trying to gain confidence through
experience and Reps and you know I
needed reps so how do you get reps you
got to be around the guy who's throwing
the ball and you know that's all you can
ask for is to be around especially with
a guy like Tom Brady who already had
three Super Bowls you know he was 35 he
was a stud for him to give me any kind
of time time would be like insane and
you know I moved out here my first year
he only called me once
dropped everything
where were you when you called I was in
a barbecue okay I was gonna barbecue
here in in Venice he's like yo a bit
because he's like he babes he babes
everyone yeah he's like oh hey babe uh
can you uh come come catch some routes
over at UCLA yeah I was like yeah I'll
be there in 10 minutes yeah yeah dropped
everything went out there doing you know
warm-ups and [ __ ] he comes out and he
[ __ ] worked me to death yeah you know
I mean I I was like we ran we must have
ran 65 70 routes which is a lot you know
you go out usually in off season
you know when you're you're running
routes you probably do you know
conditioning you'll hit like 25 to 30
routes afterwards very specialized and
detail but you know he was over we were
over here doing two minute drill going
set to 10 go down take a minute break
come back and all the that kind of work
prepare me because he was learning my
body mechanics and I was learning
ultimately what he wanted you know if he
was yelling he would yell at me on like
an out route like Yo dude you got to get
downhill on this one you know cover four
you know talking football with the guy
who's ultimately
Distributing the footballs in the
driver's seat but you know I remember
you know from uh I've seen both of the
the documentaries that they're so
[ __ ] I mean like me and my my kid a
little Bill we we like watch him over
and over again I'm gonna talk to you
about him a little bit too but but uh
you know um Brady like says on there you
were like a like a [ __ ] golden
retriever you're just like like your
work ethic was so apparent to him like
right off the the jump and I'm just
wondering like I get it like you guys
are learning each other but at that
point he wasn't really looking at you as
like this guy could be this guy could
potentially be like my you know what you
ended up as right but what it would he
run 75 routes was that with everyone or
was there something different about the
way you were doing it like how do you
feel like when you're working out with
your quarterback like what is the proper
way to do it should you when you catch
the ball are you coming full speed
backhanding in the ball like what made
you different how did you show your work
ethic I think I think we were both using
each other for different reasons I was
using him just to be seen just to let
him know you know I'm here sure uh he
was using me because he needed to throw
the ball and you know you need to throw
the ball to move in targets and
especially guys that know your system
you can sit and talk football and you
know you're sharpening your brain in the
off season when you can sit and talk
play you say hey you're the F zero out
slot thing ride 134 FBO ice you know you
gotta and so like we're talking football
so it's helping him stay in shape
mentally physically and for me it was
like I what I did I was just available
yeah yeah that was the one thing like I
I always told him if you need anyone I'm
I'm there you know that I'd drop
anything because
you know I
I loved football and I I was you know
when you get in this like sense of
unknown you know you're getting
something new yeah you know I never
played receiver you you're like a
cornered animal you gotta I was always
taught you gotta work your way out of it
you got to do everything you can to get
out of it how do you get out of it how
do you get confident work and who taught
you that and and and you know you're uh
your pops man I I really want to like uh
I'm so I'm so fascinated by your guys
relationship and uh again I'm I uh my
dad coached me uh I'm I'm the father of
athletes and and my nine-year-old plays
quarterback had a you know he's pretty
phenomenal he kind of shits on all these
dudes in basketball and stuff already
but he plays baseball and basketball and
all that and I really want to um I won't
talk about that I mean like how would
you how would you how would you describe
your old man and how would you describe
um how would you describe like what
sports the the bond between you and like
how Sports is has played a played a role
yeah my pop you know he uh he grew up
without a dad his dad died when he was
three and uh he was in and out of
trailer parks mom you know my grandma
had like three or four different
husbands and you know so it was a
different life than what I was and his
dream always was
to have a father and have
you know a relationship with someone
that could help him because he always
remembered when he was playing sports he
was a stud
but he was never quite better than the
guy that had his dad pushing him you
know and so that's why he ended up
quitting Sports to go out become a
mechanic help his mom and he learned you
know ultimately the root of hard work
through that process now when he had me
you know he
his dream was you know to basically give
me what he never had you know that
support system and I was like a knuckle
I was a wild kid and he knew how to
handle me you know he he pushed me very
hard he was very tough on me this was
the 90s you know like this shit's not
you couldn't do something like that now
yeah you know so I learned from him
through our hard work you know we
practice every day whether it was
football baseball basketball my dad
would go to work at 4 30 or 5 30 come
home at four pick me up before practice
we go hey infield take batting practice
you know get some extra reps some
football catching balls throwing balls
before practice then we go do homework
after he was just always there you know
and and I think seeing his hard work
uh through example of how he worked and
then his dedication to the you know the
kids me my brother and sister
you know that kind of when you're a kid
you are what you you're around that's
right and so when you're around that you
know I picked that up and you know he
was always the voice in my head when I I
then went off without him I went to
college he was always that voice in my
head that was always talking to me
because I could always remember the
little [ __ ] he would do to me like when
I was taking infields to have my sister
like throwing like wiffle balls at me
and and trying to bug me and and I would
get so pissed off and right I was a
firecracker and I'm like what the [ __ ]
what's going on he's like I stopped that
[ __ ] yeah he'd be like
you're not going to make it because your
mentality like your mental games out
there yeah you know what I mean like if
you can't handle this what makes you
think you can handle other people yeah
and he would challenge me this like when
I was 11 years old right 12 years old
right and so and in the moment what
would that what would that how would
that make you feel
see
I would get pissed off and try to prove
him wrong like that was me you know like
he knew what bus buttons to push with me
to to piss me off and that's the kind of
person I am now people are different
some people can't be coached hard they
need to be loved up a little more you
know everyone's a little different but
with me he knew that I needed that in
order to get pissed off work hard Focus
up like all these little factors these
fundamentals that have helped me succeed
in my life like he knew that at a young
age did you coach your brother and
sister in the same way like in this was
his style his style or did no his sign
was his style he coached my brother and
my brother you know he couldn't take it
as much how so you know he's just you
know we're you know every kid's
different and I was like how would it
manifest itself yeah he my brother like
he would I wouldn't say he would back
down but it was a different situation
and my brother had a different dad my
dad raised him and it was just kind of
it was a different situation he he would
get hard on my brother and my brother
you know wouldn't react the way I
reacted you know my sister it was
different
by the time he got done with me she's
younger than me he's like man I probably
abused this kid I can't do this to a
little girl so you know it was different
with her but you know it it goes to like
for like especially your parents that
coach their kids
you know you got to know your kid yeah
and you got to know what buttons to push
and and we fell into the situation but
with me and him were you know I was the
kind of kid if you were to challenge me
like that would fire me up and I wanted
to prove someone wrong I wanted to like
because he yelled at me or something he
threw a fastball at me I was just
sitting there and I wanted to just like
shut his ass up because he was bitching
the whole time to me so it made me focus
and I played better angry you know what
I mean my brother didn't necessarily do
that yup yup yup so and when he was
coaching the other kids on the team
because he was coaching your Peewee team
was he that same way with them like was
he oh he was he was terrifying yeah he
was he was that guy he was that guy yeah
they were tough it was a tough group
back then you know when we played Pop
Warner and [ __ ] like
it was uh
you know it was different I mean you
gotta you got a a 33 year old coach with
a dip in yeah and like croakies like
[ __ ] these kids that's right
making us puke because like there's a
special formula in pop one or there's
like a number of players you wanted
because MPR the you had to play a
certain amount of plays if you had like
33 you guys got to play 12 plays again
yes yeah so there was like that special
number so we'd start out with kids you
would try to run these kids they [ __ ]
quit
so you get the the team right you know
what I mean and we want Super Bowl Zone
and [ __ ] like we were I remember going
to high school after like pop warner
thinking it was soft yeah yeah because
of how like disciplined we were we were
well coached yeah you know it was a
testament to you know not only my father
but the other coaches along that program
so yeah
[Music]